Surprise you to know that we are still
learning so much about our own solar
system.
Even the question about how many planets
are there is kind of a funny one like
take Pluto.
Pluto was classified as a dwarf planets
and there are other dwarf planets as
well.
In fact,
the largest of the asteroid ceres is now
classified as a dwarf planet.
A lot of these dwarf planets actually
exist far through beyond the orbit of
Pluto and we're just finding them now
and one of my favorite discoveries
recently has been something called the
Goblin.
Now the Goblin is a dwarf planet.
It's actually much smaller than Pluto.
It's only about a fifth day number two
and it is really,
really far out there.
It's in a highly elongated orbit.
The closest it ever gets is about twice
as far away as Pluto is and the farthest
gets is about 2100 times the distance
from the earth to the sun.
It goes way,
way,
way out there.
This orbit takes it about 40,000 years
to go once around the sun.
It's really,
really incredible.
It doesn't surprise me that these
objects are only recently being
discovered because most of them are so
distant.
They are so faint and if they're at the
very far part of their orbit,
they're moving very,
very slowly,
very,
very hard to detect.
Now,
the Goblin is really interesting in a
number of ways.
One of the things that I love about it
is that it does actually seem to hint
that there may be something larger out
there,
and we've been noticing this for the
last couple of years.
These distant icy bodies are called
Kuyper belt objects and often they're on
a long gated orbits.
They come close to the sun and by close
I mean about the orbit of Pluto and then
much,
much farther away into the very outer
reaches of the solar system.
We now know of dozens of these objects
and there are probably many more out
there we haven't discovered.
The interesting thing is we began to
observe how their orbits were aligned in
our solar system.
There's something called Para Helion,
which is the closest pass and object
makes to the sun.
And Amazingly,
all of these objects all over the sky
seemed to have para helium's closest
approaches to the son that were
beautifully lined up together.
There is no reason for that to be the
case if they were independent orbiting
bodies,
there's no way they're closest approach
to the sun.
It should match.
So the idea is there's a larger body out
there somewhere,
a larger planet,
and as it orbits it lines up kind of
shepherds,
all these smaller objects into its
orbit.
The evidence for this really is pretty
compelling.
We don't know of any other way to
explain the lined up orbits of these
Kuyper belt objects.
So then the question is,
where is this bigger planet?
Our estimates put it at at least three
to five times the mass of the earth,
maybe even a little bit more massive
than that.
It could be something on the order of
the size of Neptune.
This is a big planet we're talking about
and honestly,
it's a little embarrassing that we've
missed an entire big planet in our solar
system.
We are now so good at detecting planets.
We can see them around other stars,
so how has it,
we've missed this planet?
Well,
if it really is very far away from us in
its orbit right now,
even a big planet would be tiny to the
most powerful telescopes so we could
have missed it.
It also would be moving so slowly that
maybe we didn't notice that it was a
planet.
Maybe people assumed it was a distant
star,
so telescopes all over the world are
scanning the sky for any sense that
there's an object out there moving very,
very slowly that could be evidence of
this giant planet.
Judging from the way these orbits are
lined up.
I think it is very likely there could be
a big planet out there and I am going to
be really happy when we have something
else to add to our knowledge of the
solar system.
There's also something kind of wonderful
happening January 1st of 2019 it's
coming up pretty soon and that is that
we're going to visit one of these Kuyper
belt objects for the very first time,
the new horizons spacecraft.
A couple of years ago,
flew by Pluto.
Hopefully you remember the beautiful
images of Pluto that it returned.
Then we aimed it at one of these distant
Kuiper belt objects.
We call it [inaudible] 69 or it's been
nicknamed ultimate Tulay,
which means far this frontier.
Now,
hopefully you're a member of the new
horizons spacecraft from his spectacular
fly by Pluto a couple of years ago.
So after it flew by Pluto,
we aimed at even farther out to
encounter one of these distant ic
objects.
It's the first time we will ever see,
but one of these objects is like after
January,
we will finally have a picture of a part
of the solar system we've never seen
before.
Yeah.